[Música]
bienvenidos a ello soy de france 24 el
15 de agosto afganistán cayó en manos
del talibán con la salida de las tropas
extranjeras la huida del presidente y la
derrota del ejército de los insurgentes
declararon un estado islámico regido por
la sharia en su interpretación más
extrema y las mujeres son las primeras
víctimas ahora con el país bajo su mando
los extremistas quieren dar una imagen
moderada y prometieron respetar la
dignidad de las mujeres y las niñas pero
dentro de la imagen sacrosanta y casta
de las leyes religiosas que ya en el
pasado desaparecieron la figura de la
mujer del espacio público restringieron
la educación y la posibilidad de ejercer
profesiones además de ser una tapadera
para los abusos las violaciones y los
matrimonios forzados en una larga lista
de violaciones
entre una multitud de personas que
intentan atravesar la barrera del
aeropuerto de kabul una niña es alzada
sobre el muro al otro lado la recibe un
soldado estadounidense
la imagen se hizo viral la razón
describe claramente el infierno de ser
mujer en afganistán bajo el régimen
talibán
más de 18.000 personas dejaron el país
desde la caída del gobierno el 15 de
agosto y otros miles presos del pánico
protagonizaron escenas de caos en el
aeropuerto de la capital tratando de
asegurarse un cupo en un avión rumbo al
extranjero
y mujeres corriendo con sus hijos
intentando escapar y en las calles
mientras las tropas estadounidenses
completan su retirada ya se sienten los
cambios pocas mujeres en el espacio
público los muros con publicidades
femeninas vandalizados
la sharía o ley islámica llevada al
extremo esgrime al menos 29
prohibiciones para las mujeres y las
niñas algunas de ellas son descritas por
la asociación revolucionaria de las
mujeres de afganistán el trabajo salir
de casa sin compañía de un hombre la
educación mostrar partes del cuerpo son
penas de castigos físicos tener sexo
fuera del matrimonio usar maquillaje que
se escuche su voz el deporte ser
visibles desde las ventanas durante la
ofensiva que terminó en la toma del país
surgieron informes del talibán yendo de
puerta en puerta haciendo listas de
mujeres y niñas de entre 12 y 45 años
para obligarlas a casarse con
combatientes islamistas la nobel de paz
y víctima de un ataque talibán en 2002
en pakistán malayos upside pidió acción
a los países y estoy profundamente
preocupada por la situación de
afganistán en este momento especialmente
por la seguridad de las mujeres y niñas
allí tuve la oportunidad de hablar con
algunas activistas en afganistán
incluidas las activistas por los
derechos de las mujeres
y ellas comparten su preocupación pues
no están seguras de cómo será su vida
una mujer bajo la ley islámica radical
es vulnerable a abusos violaciones y
maltratos sin voz desaparece cuando los
extremistas gobernaron el país por
última vez entre 1996 y 2001 a las niñas
no se les permitía estudiar las mujeres
no podían trabajar y tenían que usar
burkas que cubrieran de pies a cabeza y
estar acompañadas por un pariente
masculinos y querían aventurarse a salir
quienes infringieron las reglas podrían
ser humilladas y sometidas a palizas
públicas por parte de la policía
religiosa del talibán
para el análisis está en ellas hoy la
doctora fernanda vidal correa ella es
profesora de e investigadora de la
universidad de panamericana y nos
acompaña desde ciudad de mexico fernanda
bienvenida a ellas hoy y hablemos de
esta toma de afganistán que ha dejado a
mujeres y niñas una generación no
completa que ha crecido con luchas por
derechos y libertades y que ahora son
las más vulnerables se arriesgan a
perder no solamente sus logros en
derechos humanos y en igualdad sino
también arriesgan su propia vida
hola qué tal así es bien lo dice son
mujeres que tal vez durante 20 años ha
vivido en un mundo completamente
distinto al que se les está planteando
desde el domingo no con la toma de kabul
son mujeres que tal vez desconocen
digamos de carne propia lo que es vivir
bajo el yugo de los talibanes lo que
significa una imposición sumamente
estricta o interpretaciones sumamente
estrictas de la ley islámica no entonces
si estamos observando aquí pues
completamente como lo hice es una
generación que está perdiendo cualquier
esperanza de poder seguir construyendo
un futuro con base en libertades sin
derechos humanos
las escenas de desesperación que hemos
visto fernanda desde la toma de
afganistán por parte del talibán son
simplemente indignante son dolorosas son
escenas que esperamos no tener que
repetir escenas de mujeres lanzando a
sus hijos por encima de muros con mallas
y con púas escenas de mujeres se
tratando de llegar al aeropuerto acomodo
del lugar sin embargo la postura del
talibán hacia la mujer ha sido una
postura modera y de un dicho respeto a
los derechos humanos es esto simplemente
una estrategia de propaganda
bueno mira lo que ellos están afirmando
es que respetarán a las mujeres dentro
del marco que provee la ley islámica y
aquí es en donde vienen muchísimas
sutilezas porque todo dependerá de cuál
sea la interpretación que se le dé a la
ley islámica tenemos por ejemplo un
instrumento internacional que es la
convención sobre la eliminación de todas
las formas de discriminación contra la
mujer que éste ha sido ratificada por
incluso estados islámicos ahora bien
está ratificada pero existe una cosa que
se llama reservas y en ese sentido
muchísimos de los países que justamente
tienen dentro de su marco legal la ley
islámica han incluido reservas a la
aplicación de esta convención por
ejemplo para que las mujeres no puedan
pasarle la nacionalidad a sus hijos para
que los estados no tengan que hacer todo
lo que esté en sus manos para generar un
marco legal donde las mujeres y los
hombres sean iguales hay reservas
vinculadas también por ejemplo a este
los derechos en movimiento a decidir
sobre su lugar de residencia dónde va a
ser su domicilio esto este conjunto de
reserva se vincula justamente a que los
países hablan acerca de que este
instrumento internacional no convive o
no corresponde con los ideales más
puestos colocados y pensados dentro de
la sharía o de la ley islámica
oliván lo diga cuando ellos gobernaron
hasta 2001 ya habíamos visto una serie
de vejámenes una serie de prohibiciones
de la educación completamente cortada la
posibilidad de ejercer profesionalmente
completamente cortada la mujer
desaparecida del espacio público y eso
es lo que más preocupa ahora a
defensores de derechos humanos la mujer
simplemente no existe y tampoco hay
manera de ver qué tanto se están
respetando o qué tanto se están violando
sus derechos humanos
quisiera preguntarle fernanda por la
práctica llamada la bacha bazi que ha
sido muy popularizada en redes sociales
en las últimas semanas y que
significaría en español algo así como
jugar con niños una práctica pederasta
que culturalmente se realiza desde hace
mucho tiempo y que caracteriza los
talibanes y una violencia que
posiblemente nació animada por esa falta
de contacto con la mujer por esa
desaparición del cuerpo femenino y de la
convivencia con la mujer hablemos de eso
si en el caso de los bachata si son
menores víctimas que son claramente
víctimas de abuso sexual no por parte de
que de hombres adultos afganos de
militares en este caso vamos a decir
incluso como de milicia no porque en ese
sentido así se están comportando
entonces afecta a niños usualmente que
concretamente proceden de familias con
escasos o nulos recursos no y entonces
de estas familias venden no trafican a
los niños oa veces incluso son tomados
de sus casas y vendidos a hombres con
muchos recursos no y entonces en ese
sentido estos estos niños básicamente
tienen que están obligados y forzados a
convivir pero es una convivencia de
naturaleza sexual con sus captores no es
un es un sistema que básicamente hasta
la fecha ha dejado impune a los
perpetradores y permite continuar con
estos ciclos de abuso sobre todo
pensando y así lo ven como una práctica
cultural que en realidad en 2017 fue
prohibida ya en términos legales dentro
del código penal afgano no es una
práctica que efectivamente ya de 2000
está prohibida más no de ninguna manera
se aplica la ley para perseguir
específicamente a las personas que están
cometiendo este tipo de delito
el talibana habla de una mujer que debe
ser casta y debe ser sacrosanta como son
esos dos términos una excusa que da pie
al tráfico de mujeres al abuso a la
violación a los castigos en público
si efectivamente digamos que dentro del
marco de la ley islámica y de acuerdo a
ciertas interpretaciones sumamente duras
y ortodoxas en la lapidación por ejemplo
es una forma aceptada de castigo y que
sea que sea utilizado y que se sabe
incluso es de las mujeres digamos
sabemos que sufren de violencia y hay en
el lugar y esto se traslada
evidentemente a la esfera pública aquí
también lo preocupante es eso que que
las mujeres desaparecen de la esfera
pública son recluidas en sus casas pero
en sus casas siguen siendo víctimas de
violencia y eso tampoco se ve
que tanto diría usted que se lograron
emancipar las mujeres afganas en los
últimos 20 años porque por supuesto
todavía se pueden ver en las fotografías
y en los vídeos que llegan en medios
internacionales pues a las mujeres
utilizando el velo islámico- la burka y
manteniéndose pegadas a las tradiciones
islámicas esto estaba cambiando y ahora
cuál es el retroceso
si digamos que hay muchas diferencias en
afganistán de acuerdo a la ubicación
geográfica de la que estemos hablando no
es lo mismo son naturales que si estamos
hablando de las mujeres que viven por
ejemplo en la ciudad de kabul no en ese
sentido es evidente que en las grandes
urbes las mujeres han logrado tomar
espacios de las cuales no eran
partícipes lo veíamos antes de la
entrada del gobierno talibán el
parlamento andando estaba constituido
por casi un 30 por ciento de mujeres en
ese sentido digamos los números nos
hablan de un buen camino y también de
grandes logros nos vemos también en
términos de la educación en donde si
bien no se alcanzan los mismos números
que se ven en el caso de los hombres
estamos viendo que cada vez más mujeres
estaban matriculando en las
universidades la educación no tenía que
ser una cosa que se diera de manera
oculta no y en ese sentido vemos que
esta nueva generación educada estaba
tomando y ahora sí que las riendas de
sus vidas no en ese sentido impulsándose
las áreas en las cuales ahora no podrán
desarrollarse gracias fernando por estar
en ellos hoy y para el cierre
simplemente les cuento un testimonio de
sarmin ya acá carl una activista por los
derechos de las mujeres de 26 años en
kabul quienes recordó para uno de
nuestros artículos de france 24 como en
un momento su madre la llevó a comprar
un helado y fue azotada por un
combatiente talibán por exponer su
rostro momentáneamente sigan con
nosotros en france 24 y volvemos
próximamente en ellas hoy
[Música]